Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
You'll never guess where I am...I'm in an
airport!
I was last in this airport so recently that
my log-in to the wireless hasn't expired.
Ok, so, yesterday, Subbable was acquired by
Patreon; that was great news, and more great
news: today is the publication day of Hold
Me Closer, David Levithan's musical novel
companion to the book we wrote together -- Will
Grayson, Will Grayson.
It's like the actual Tiny Cooper musical from
Will Grayson, Will Grayson; it's fantastic.
And in even more great news: the Paper Towns
trailer comes out on Thursday which is why
I'm in the airport; because I have to go be
on The Today Show.
Also, 100% of my current children have vomited
on me in the past 24 hours, so I'm a little
nervous that I might get a stomach bug and
then throw up on The Today Show, which would
be very problematic on a number of fronts,
but especially, like, the GIFs?
I just keep imagining the GIFs of me throwing
up on Matt Lauer...
Anyway, giving the forthcoming release of
the trailer, I've been thinking a lot about
the phrase "Paper Towns".
Like in the book it means different things
to Q, the narrator, at different points in
the story.
But in real life, as you know Hank, the phrase
"Paper Towns" is about copyright.
Like mapmakers create fictitious entries in
their map to make sure that no one else is
copying them.
Like if you put my fake place on your map,
I know that you've stolen from me.
Every map company does this, Hank.
Like Google Maps does it all the time; they
probably created a paper town called Argelton
in England.
But you see it all the time.
It's usually not paper towns; it's usually
like paper streets or paper bridges.
My favorite example of this aside from Agloe,
New York (the one that I use in Paper Towns)
is Beatosu, Ohio, which is a town created
by mapmakers who were fans of the University
of Michigan's football team and wanted them
to "beat OSU."
But Hank, these copyright traps aren't just
limited to mapmaking; you see them everywhere.
In encyclopedias, in dictionaries, in paleontology
textbooks.
Like in Paper Towns, Margo's dog is named
Myrna Mountweasel in honor of this fictitious
entry from the New Columbia Encyclopedia about
Lillian Virginia Mountweasel.
The encyclopedia said that she was a fountain
designer and photographer who died in an explosion
while on assignment for Combustibles Magazine.
I'm just totally fascinated by how much fictional
information is floating around in the non-fictional
world, you know?
Like Google recently used fictitious entries
against Bing.
The Billboard Charts have used them; but my
favorite example comes from the New Oxford
American Dictionary.
The word esquivesence...nope, it's esquivalence...
I'm sorry, sometimes I mix up my nonexistent
words.
Esquivalence or maybe it's esquivalience...it
occurs to me that I have no idea how to pronounce
this fictional word.
Anyway, it's defined as avoiding one's official
responsibilities, you know, as a thieving
lexicographer would.
And the crazy thing about esquivalience is
that like Agloe, NY and many other fictitious
entries, it has kind of become real.
Like it's in a bunch of dictionaries now,
and the Apple dictionary even gives it a fictional
etymology.
Now, like obviously this is an appealing idea
for a writer because I need to believe that
made-up stories can really matter in the lives
of real people.
But it also reminds me that yes, obviously
language shapes the dictionary, but the dictionary
also shapes the language.
And Hank, I guess I kind of think it is the
official responsibility of us as human beings
to try to imagine the world around us as complexly
and interestingly as we can.
And on that front at least, let us endeavor
not to be esquivalient.
I hope you like the Paper Towns movie trailer;
it comes out on Thursday.
I will see you on Friday!